hallo mein name ist luca und du hast gar
keine muskeln urdorf geld denkt doch
tragen willkommen hier zu einer weiteren
folge
wieso weitere folge ich habe das noch
nie gemacht letztes mal als ich diesen
stift in der hand hatte habe ich eure
snap chat bilder gemalt allerdings habe
ich mir heute gedacht dass ich mir ein
paar bilder von youtube suche und die
versuche nach zu malen so was gibt es
bestimmt schon irgendwo auf youtube
allerdings noch nicht von jemandem der
überhaupt nicht mahlen kann und das bin
ich und ich habe mir jetzt drei youtuber
bilder ausgesucht ersten youtuber habe
ich hier mich rausgesucht damit nicht
irgendwer schreiben kann hey du
schaltest alle youtuber weil dann
veranstaltet ich mich selbst auch und
ich habe jetzt nicht mehr wir fangen
einfach an
[Musik]
ich glaube ich habe vorhin die hautfarbe
komplett falsch ausgewählt meine
hautfarbe ist definitiv nicht orange
luca das ist einfach so mega tillich
habe man einfach kein strässer sonst
liegt ja immer nebenher noch dieser drei
minuten später dass man nur so ganz
wenig zeit hatte aber jetzt ist es
einfach so richtig nein man kann so
alles ganz in ruhe auswählen man kann
nicht so genau überlegen ok welche farbe
nämlich jetzt beispielsweise im rucksack
und wolle er war man hat einfach gar
kein stress und ich denke also ich denke
nur ich kann euch ja keinen natürlich
keine garantie jetzt geben ich denke
dass dieses bild am ende gar nicht mal
so hässlich sein wird aber ich möchte
nichts versprechen weil es kann
natürlich auch später wieder hässlich
sein und das denke ich sogar dass es
später wieder herzlich
[Musik]
ohne witz wie macht man eine blonde
haare
sie sehen auf diesem bild jetzt liegen
die folge aus weil ich halt diesen
hintergrund so ein bisschen denen dings
wieder auf nur 50 prozent gestellt habe
aber wie macht man blonde haare es gibt
doch nur geld als ich meinen braune
haare und schwarze haare blond ich mein
welche haarfarbe habe ich natürlich
blond aber welche farbe ist das ist
blond ist doch keine farbe schaut euch
das mal an was ist das das ist das schon
braun oder was ist das ich glaube das
wird er später irgendwann station bild
oder irgend so ein typ von dragon balls
im dragon ball nicht ganz geschafft aber
das ist doch echt hier die gibt also die
ich mich schon wieder mal eine das ist
doch echt unterirdische fragt mich nicht
was ich je grad uhr
ich weiß es selber nicht das soll
irgendwie die kontur von meinen haaren
darstellen aber ich bin mir ganz sicher
dass das nachher wieder einfach nur wie
ein stück scheiße aus alter das ist doch
nicht wahr
also ich weiß echt nicht wieder später
aussehen wird und ihr müsstet mir jetzt
mal die kommentare schreiben ob ihr
später eventuell das wieder mit einem
timer haben wollt oder wieder mit snap
chat bildern oder was weiß ich ob ich
das gefällt aber so wie ich das gerade
hier gibt es einfach nur mega kacke ich
weiß dass sich grüne augen habe das
heißt da kommt gleich auf jeden fall
noch irgendwas grünes muss da rein aber
ich bin mir überhaupt nicht sicher wie
das aussehen wird
oh mein gott freunde ich glaube an in
denen wir sind noch nicht fertig ich
muss auch das kondom schnell machen und
die konturen vom pullover und das was
ich jetzt achte ich hier sogar auf diese
ganzen kleinen details alter okay ich
denke wir sind jetzt mehr oder weniger
fertig ich bin mir nicht sicher wie es
aussehen wird wir werden natürlich
wieder das obere bild weil eben schnell
auf 100 prozent stellen das heißt ihr
geht jetzt so sieht das normale bild aus
da sieht jetzt so genau nochmal die
haarfarbe die das ganze hier aussieht
und wenn wir uns das jetzt mal anschauen
was das verschieben werden ihr sagt
nicht jetzt prämiert das ist doch nicht
war okay ich hab sie das hingekriegt
also das hier ist das ursprungs bild mit
dem wir ausgegangen sind und jetzt
schauen wir uns meine zeichnung davon
ein ich glaube
sie ist nicht schlimm ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass sie weder meine fresse
alter ja gut also so ein bisschen sieht
aus wie ich dass das muss ich schon
lassen also schaut euch das haben und
schaut euch das an
ich meine so schlimm ist es nicht ich
denke wenn man das bild kennt kann man
nicht darauf erkennen aber es ist halt
trotzdem guckt euch diese fucking augen
an alter das sieht aus wie grüne
spiegeleier hier speichern das bild aber
natürlich wieder ab falls ich die mal
irgendwem auf dem video der schenken
sollte und hat keine ahnung was ich
glaube dass wir sogar gar keine haben
als zweites bild habe ich mir
irgendeinen von den beiden zwillingen
von tv genommen ich weiß nicht ob das
tennis oder benny oder wellness oder
danny oder irgendwer von den beiden ist
es glaube ich auf jeden fall und den
werde ich jetzt mal ich werde wie ich
versuchen ein wenig länger zu halten das
video ist nämlich schon mal 15 minuten
das heißt ich aber leider mir schon
richtig lange gemalt aber wir fangen
einfach mal an ich glaube das bild wird
stark also noch mal an dieser stelle
dennis oder benny oder wer von euch
beiden auch immer dieses bild dieser typ
auf diesem bild ist ich glaube ich
veranstalte euch gar nicht mal so krass
also ich bin mir nicht sicher wie ich
dass sie mit den haarfarben hinkriegen
soll oder was weiß ich aber ich denke
das bild wird später einen tollen platz
in eurem www studio erhalten da bin ich
mir relativ sicher mein gott freunde die
haare sind stark getroffen oder also ich
finde jetzt gar nicht mal so schlimm
bisher ich denke das bild könne nicht
nachher richtig geil werden unter dem
snap chetwie gemeinten viele dass sich
die konturen vergessen habe bei haaren
oder beim bad oder was weiß ich
deswegen trägt er dennis oder bl sorry
aber ich weiß wirklich nicht wer von
beiden das ist wie kann man die
auseinanderhalten
[Musik]
und ich meine dann hätten was auch schon
oder ich meine das ganze bild das
besteht ja nicht aus mehr das ist ja nur
er da irgendwie in die kamera schaut da
ist ja kein großes teiligen out von oder
sonst was
deswegen freuen ich bin mir recht sicher
dieses bild kann nicht schlecht sein ich
habe nicht viel falsch gemacht
unfassbar leid wer von euch beiden das
ist dass ich dachte es wird hübsch ich
denke das hübscheste sind die haare also
ich finde sogar wenn man das hier oben
so abschneiden würde so nur hier oben
dann ist es richtig heiß allerdings dann
kommen die augen die so komplett
verdreht sind und vom rest muss ich
glaube ich gar nicht erst anfangen also
das ist dennis oder benny oder wer ist
das steht da ist ein strich reingekommen
beim verziehen auch scheißegal der macht
das bild sogar noch schöner als drittes
bild hp wieso ist meine softbox von ihr
ausgegangen ich habe mir julien beer
ausgesucht und den werde ich jetzt
verschönern
also ich finde die hautfarbe bisher hab
ich unfassbar toll getroffen ich musste
übrigens das bild auch ein wenig drehen
weil er das leben auf den kopf gemacht
hat aber ich denke dass heute keine das
ist ein bisschen komisch ich glaube das
komplette bild ist irgendwie schwarz ich
kann ja eigentlich alles drum rum erst
mal schwarz machen
[Musik]
ok also bisher muss ich echt sagen so
viel konnte ich bisher nicht falsch
machen das meiste schwarz die hautfarbe
geld natürlich ist klar aber ja okay das
tattoo dabei können nicht krass
verpacken
ich fühle mich gerade so ein bisschen
wie picasso oder wie irgend so ein typ
der das kann weil ich immer so richtig
viele stiche jetzt setzte beim bad oder
bei tattoos oder was weiß ich aber da
fühlt man sich dann echt so wenn man
ganz viele striche macht so als wenn man
so irgendwie sondern so einen künstler
dass das hat nicht gesehen bisher finde
ich stark
okay was heißt bisher ich bin so gut wie
fertig machen noch ein paar ansätze im
bereich aber sondern freunde ich bin
zufrieden mit meiner arbeit bisher ich
bin vollkommen zufrieden wo man dazu
natürlich ergänzt muss das ich bisher
mit jeder arbeit zufrieden war und jedes
bild mich am ende trotzdem voll ins
enttäuscht halbfeld as we say die haare
sehen aus wie spinnen aber an
das sind nur die um mein gott sind die
ansätze hey alter okay
vielleicht sind die haare scheiße
geworden müller hat aber damit ihr dann
berechtigt dann auch noch die nase
komplett vergeben
dann packe ich noch eben hier unten in
die jacke so ein paar helle konturen
rein so dass das ganze auch so aus als
hätte die jacke so ein paar schatten
jetzt fühle ich nicht mal eben wieder
schnell kurz sowie die kasse das war's
ich denke wir sind mit julian beim ganz
gut klar gekommen also wir schauen uns
das originalbild an das sieht nämlich so
aus und jetzt meine damen und herren
kommt der moment der wahrheit das
zeichen pad kann schon mal zur seite
geworfen werden und wir schauen uns das
bild an was ich von julien gemalt habe
[Musik]
was zum teufel namen habe ich kreiert
sehr guter standard foto ist ein ganz
süßer und jetzt viel viel knuffiger alu
komplettes kinder unten vergriffen ich
habe einfach den bart als kind
begrenzung genommen aber naja so
unwirklich einen hals abschnitt hat oder
nicht aber ich das tattoo gegen
eigentlich ganz gut klar ich weiß nicht
genau wie es jetzt hier ja gut ist
bestimmt irgendwie ein chinesisches
schriftzeichen oder irgendwas aber bei
mir ist es einfach und halb im juli an
ich habe dich gezeichneten mich bitte ab
sofort nur noch pkw 4 picasso
geschrieben okay so wie ich geschrieben
hat war richtig nämlich geht ab sofort
nur noch picassos so jetzt mal hier noch
schön hier damit keiner sich beschweren
kann irgendwie mit mit
rechtschreibfehlern oder punktierung
oder irgendwie so und jetzt kriegt er
das erst mal schön gibt oder ist dieses
bild nicht wundervoll
also ich muss wirklich sagen dass es
doch rheins der kunst ja freunde wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat und ihr
eventuell noch mal so ein ich mal
irgendwas mit dem x pert video sehen
wollt dann schreibt mir doch mal und in
die kommentare was ich mit dem x pert
malen sollte ich freue mich über eine
bewertung und ich rede gerade so wie ein
roboter